I used to collect animals I had this big
table I painted the color like National
Geographic binder and put a lip on it
had a glass lid and I had like grizzly
bear feeding on whitebark pine nuts
grizzly bear feeding on elk grizzly bear
feeding on grass
I had a black bear that sow a bear claw
I had a coyote out of fawns hoof
I had like just an amazing collection so
people always like to have it laughs
like oh you dumb redneck but there's a
lot you can tell from looking at
touching examining animals I'm Steven
Rinella I'm a hunter and a tracker and
this is the breakdown this is the last
of the Mohicans
we pause this here I already don't like
it tracking is like following an
animal's trail unless you're in brand
speak Edie new fresh snow
it is a painstakingly slow process and
I'll often see in movies you have people
like these fellers here hauling it
through the woods tracking something it
just never happens
dogs can't move a trail fast he still
has to stop and grub it out and put his
nose in there and smell it nothing goes
fast like this he stops to look at a
mossy Rock his physicality is like aha
just what I'm looking for on the top of
this mossy rock I mean it's not like
he's got an arm
the deers got an arm that he reaches out
like scratches the mossy Rock okay it's
not even one that can be really taken
seriously its forward a bit
stop here I think directors are always
let down by the animals that live on the
continent where they're filming I feel
the directors when they're they're not
outdoorsmen and then some person the
props person whoever - held an animal
handler presents them with a suite of
plausible animals the ones that would be
there always seem to not like measure up
to their expectations and they lean into
the majestic European stay for a guy
like me to watch I always watch this
stuff it just makes me depressed if you
like animals you like being out around
animals and experiencing animals you
fall in love with the way nature is and
then you watch film renditions of it and
they don't love what it is they wish it
was different you know and I like who
are you to wish nature behaved
differently than it does when it and of
itself is perfect from a marksmanship
standpoint if something's running you
need to have follow-through say they
like shooting skeet or trap the shotgun
the key is the objects moving you need
to as it will say that can you to paint
it out of the sky the unforgiving sin is
he does is leave it then goes hurt deers
gone man you can't it's like yeah go
ahead follow through so yeah then he's
just totally chill he stops totally
chill enrolls it like act over teakettle
I am no shot place but get you that not
long ago we were having this
conversation I proposed a friend I'm
like why don't they bring in expert
bring it a guy who would be like no no
no you know it'd be more like this
someone said they do but they don't
listen to him it's not a good scene the
good the bad and the ugly everything
about this movie is perfect I mean just
promote from a cinematic experience just
a great movie man
a nice thing about tracking scenes for
the track and on horseback is it sort of
negates what I was saying earlier about
how slow everything is like the horse
leaves a peg at the track especially
wearing a shoe it gouge is the ground up
but when you're looking at animal sign
or any kind of any kind of trails or
tracks on the ground there's a
tremendous amount of noise going on
there are all these organisms okay that
are that are in this area if you're on a
trail there's a lot of things using the
trail so when I say noises that animals
tracks get lost and the noise of other
tracks there's just tons of noise out
there so if he's hauling it you sort of
have to give him the room to be that
there's not a lot of noise there hasn't
been a lot of other horsemen around in
the area in a low traffic area I'll give
him the benefit of the doubt what is
cool this legit he's testing the
freshness of the trail by seeing about
the warmth of the embers on the fire
which is it is totally fair and it's
still today manly you can feel like a
really really fresh animal like a really
fresh bear you can put your hand on it
and feel the temp oh man I touched bears
but all the time like a touch of my hand
or touch with my boot he takes a drag he
likes what he's tasting and then as he
should he looks up because he's not too
far off if you find a cigar that's still
smoking or a cigarette that's still
smoking to something but smoked it's not
far away now this would lead me to
believe that Clint Eastwood's making
fires within minutes of themselves
because his last fire was still smoking
so he's like colder and he'll but his
last fire was still smoking this fire
smoke and Clint's making a lot of fires
and this guy's on door let's say that
this guy's hauling at the horse bag and
he's really like pouring the coals to it
moving along on horseback is it
plausible to keep track and someone long
it depends it depends on the weather if
you're in a dry location where it's not
raining something's making a track on a
fairly undisturbed surface the tracking
lasts for days
will often find like if we'll be looking
for elk will find elk tracks or deer
tracks that you know it could be weeks
old it's hard to follow it it's hard to
imagine it like this continuous line
flowing it's more like over her
snippets of conversation that you're
picking up when you're in a sort of a
mixed landscape but yeah running around
the desert on a road no other dude rode
a horse - yeah I can see it let's say
you're following a trail and you lose it
you got it pretty good wherever you're
following tracks and all sudden
something happens we call it cutting
cookies or caught in circles I'll do a
short one then that doesn't work I'll
bump out depending on what's going on
I'll bump out five feet 50 yards I don't
know I'll do another half circle I'll
bump out and do another half circle
broadening my range trying to find where
that thing passed through again go to a
great location where it's for sure gonna
leave a trail or just start looping like
scent dog and just looking around
looking around looking around wedding
crashers why do I have to be in
camouflage of the big bad quill doesn't
see me stop here yeah they stole this
mail more fun you're doing a thing like
oh you know hunters are so stupid Elmer
Fudd so funny they give them like a year
flap hat I don't want with anyone who
like puts the eager flap hat on it's
warm out Elmer Fudd needs to sue whoever
made this movie Hollywood loves beatin
steaks and restaurants and they love
that people that hunt for stuff and eat
it are just rednecks but let's go on if
I was Vince Vaughn I'd have that shotgun
up that guy's by now oh no there he goes
he brushes it away okay he's getting the
vibe it's not desirable okay freezes
friend one thing real bad two things
good he's got control of the weapon it's
not flopping around laxed
lackadaisically he's got it under his
control the problem is he has his finger
in the trigger guard the reason you
wouldn't want to put your finger in the
trigger guard is cuz that's where the
trigger is
and once you hit the trigger there's a
strong probability of the gun going off
my 9 year old would no way in the world
walk around with his finger in the
trigger guard like that don't put your
finger on the trigger so you want that
thing to go off or to you're like ready
to shoot so now here's the whole crew
they're doing what we what'd you call it
drive where you're trying to flush game
and you're moving through good habitat
trying to flush game if you were doing
that you would never be like that close
to people if you still maintain a
distance of 10 yards at a minimum so
these guys are packed up he's got his
finger where it's supposed to be my
guess is at Bradley Cooper in his past
has had some exposure to firearms it's a
very natural finger position and a very
natural carry and leaning up like that
like if you're walking in the line
people in front of you like it's okay to
do that what are they shooting at like
they're shooting and aiming but there's
nothing there - Amex is just he's just
saying to the right so it's like oh I
get it they're so trigger-happy they
just would just shoot to the right
because someone said shoot to the right
in the absence of any visual target they
don't know what's going on when Wilson
shoots and it's like someone's tied a
rope from a car to his back and is
dragging him through the woods
why is his recoil so much more abusive
than his compatriots the recoils of
their shotguns
it's like watching Elmer Fudd like it's
just cartoony and it's got an agenda
that makes me uncomfortable the revenant
this is the real what actually happens
here the Hugh glass story gets mauled by
a grizzly two other trappers mountain
men are supposed to stay with him and
the assumption is gonna die overnight so
Jim Bridger another guy are Taft's to
stay with him and watch him die and they
get chicken they're trespassing on
Indian lands they're afraid of
retribution from the tribe so they split
and in real life Hugh glass then has
this harrowing journey crawls back the
civilization confronts the guys that
left him and takes no vengeance so the
story is a story of like forgiveness its
fortitude and forgiveness then it gets
turned into a movie and it winds up turn
into this big vengeance tale of
just like they just add all this bull
didn't like the guy killed his kid and
he's got to track down and kills him and
it just twists like what was the purpose
that the story's always served about
resilience and forgiveness I am it's
good job he's got an outer hat I see
which I'm jealous over costumes are good
we haven't done a lot of fighting in the
early 1800s but it's all seems good here
let me jump ahead see here he's got an
advantage in that they're tracking and
fresh snow it is gonna be extremely
difficult to lose that trail and you'd
be able to run that trail as fast as you
could run so here if he's gonna like
haul down this one yeah man he's got a
he's got a great little bit of trail
foul and ahead of him if you really
wanted to trail that for a long time he
goes in that powder and then it gets
warm during the day and that snow
softens up and then it gets cold at
night and that snow freezes it like
encases that track and then that track
will hold that track will stay relevant
for a long time in an additional thing
it's in that pre high elevation deep
snow situation probably not a lot of
big-game animals around probably not a
lot of elk around and other stuff that
could create other noise and confusion
when your file on the trail you can
switch over to a stick a moose oaf on
there but the it's just humans and
animals don't walk the same you know
we're a little bit similar to a bear our
placement but again a bear's got too
many feet now he's an area with a lot
less snowfall this guy's got his he's
got his groove down good he knows to
move very slowly like eyes pick up
movement eyes pick up fast movement slow
movement is hard to pick up I was so
depressed during this whole movie I
wanted to like it bad out of Africa
I already like it I've never seen this
move but I already like it cuz those are
some great looking prints man it's like
a good looking track and around a good
looking trail here we have like an
African tracker tracking native game in
Africa and so the poetic license or
freedom that I'm gonna give this guy is
great and I'm expecting to see some like
Herculean tracking efforts okay she's
gonna blow this guy right in the back of
that gun not great muzzle control that
would make me real uneasy to have two
guns trained on my back line therefore
the winds behind we haven't touched on
wind animals smell things where if a
smell hits them it's almost like it's
giving it a blow meaning it'll like
react the way you might react from the
knowledge and my fist is coming toward
your face they feel smell we even do a
thing called wind bumping so let's say
you got a thicket you know it could be
something hiding out in the thicket you
could pass through up here let that wind
to carry your scent down and scent bump
it when you have topography like honey
Mountain hunting you know that when the
air cools the air will drop when it
warms it'll rise you're on a slope here
okay and there's something there's a elk
here and you're gonna be going up like
this to find that elk and in the morning
it might be the descent because the air
is cooling coldest part of the day in
the morning that cold air is gonna wash
down then the day is gonna warm up the
sun's gonna come up they'll see the Sun
you'll feel the temperature change it'll
come up with degree and all of a sudden
that air will wash back up in terms of
stalking or tracking or anything or
always thinking about what are the
thermals doing right now you can be in
the area like you could be in a valley
let's say here's the whatever here's a
valley kay and where my hands come
together is a stream coming down you
could be on the side of the valley and
have a side slope but if this thing's
got a stream in it and it's got cold
water and that cold waters rushing
downhill that cold water that's right
here will cool the air enough it'll
create a downstream thermal running down
along the top of that water because the
water cools the air and the cold air
goes down so you could be in a situation
where you're trying to stalk something
but the winds no good
getting that creek bed and walk right up
that creek bed and you're taking
advantage of this down washing airflow
that defies the the dominant wind
direction it could be washing across
spilling down the hill or crossways
around the hill so like that Robert
Redford here the fact that he's aware of
wind is cool I like it it's a great
mention the fact that he thinks that the
wind is gonna make it come into him and
attack him I feel like the other day
opposite would happen did pick up his
older slip out
oh it's plausible you could get up back
close to something that's feeding on
something they wouldn't know you're
there because especially guys are so
distracted they have like a lot they're
paying attention to if it was just
bedded down no you don't get up they're
gonna any kind of distance but like but
spatially I'm not clear a couple years
ago my brother lives in Alaska he was
going up a river moose on and he passes
this camp he shoots a guy and their hunt
gets over to get back to town he's
reading the newspaper about a guy that
got mauled by a grizzly on the same
river he was hunting the lo and behold
here's the picture of the victim the
victim is the dude he was just talking
to he had been talking to on his way up
the river what happen the bad guy is
that guy had stumbled into the carcass
of a different moose hunter and the bear
had claimed the carcass he stumbles into
it the bear gets pissed and in malls
them grizzly bears or brown bears will
attack things because the things scared
him if something comes up it startles
you or thinks that the animal thinks
you're gonna take its food or thinks
you're gonna hurt its cub it just wham
wants to neutralize a threat like that's
how most people get attacked by grizzly
bears if I was going through the woods
and I also didn't face a face with a
large predator want seem very unpro like
arms in the air I'm going hey well hey
hey a whole bunch arms up
if you risk someone you get close
together everybody's eyes are up you're
yelling loud and you're walking away
you're not turning tail and running
cause when you're turning tail and
running you could like trigger this sort
of predatory thing like oh I was gonna
eat it now it's getting away let me go
get it instead you're like don't mess
with me I'm walking away from you if it
doesn't know you're there like you walk
up there's a moose carcass laying there
and there's a bear on it I would very
quietly just get the hell out of there
the hell they doing in this movie
anyways I don't even know what this
movie's about
here comes the lioness I am rolls it now
here comes the oh yeah yeah I'll buy it
I'll buy it
that's fine people nowadays might have a
different appetite toward that but in a
situation like that man I wouldn't do
anything differently than that this is
Jeremiah Johnson this is my favorite
movies of all time for me and my peers
growing up we all wanted to be mountain
men this was like our anthem anthem
here's an American elf in where he
should be that elk is out there and it's
doing the rush and he's buting like
movies because his breeding seasons a
bowl has this he's got to know a number
noises he'll make two though they'll go
in there talking to each other
softly but they also just sit out there
going like when y'all the mountains and
their beetles too perfect you like
that's probably a dude the elk call that
gives you the greatest range of
possibilities this thing called the
diaphragm call it's a little piece of
latex that goes into your mouth you take
your tongue and force it against the
roof your mouth so you're closing off
all air passage and you're just rocking
you exhale from the diaphragm and you
can take that thing in your mouth and
you can you can make a wide array of elk
sounds my feeling is that they're just
dubbing in the sound of a bugle to make
them seem like he's up there bu boom but
I don't think that's what that Elex
doing it looks uneasy see he's gonna hit
this ball he gets a very good hit on
this bowl I would bet you that opal shop
just everything about you can't fake it
I'm not saying it's him but that elk is
shot by a firearm let's go back
the strategy is legit because at this
time in American history there's a great
abundance of feral horses on the
landscape all across the American West
the fact that this thing's like
comfortable the horse coming by sure the
deer hunter
[Music]
heroin moving topography looks good
outfits look good the back tags is a
nice touch back tags are fading out now
but in this area you had to wear your
license on your back so it's good they
had the back tags thrown in there it's
meant to be that a game warden or
whoever could just look at you walking
away and see your license number they're
less common ah we've kind of gotten away
from bag tags one of these guys seems to
be following blaze orange laws and
someone does most places when you're
hunting with a firearm during firearm
deer season you have to wear a blaze
orange because it's easily identifiable
and visual to other hunters when they
introduce blaze orange laws it really
had a pretty sudden and dramatic impact
on hunting accidents just people being
able to see each other here's where
everything gets horrible the thing is
he's hunting deer and everything looks
good but they did the thing where they
insert the wrong damn animal if I was
him I'd be like dude this is gonna not
work out but he stays on he stays on it
this is like very typical where you
catch a glimpse and like here's this
thing and it goes over the hill so you
quickly but quietly move and try to
anticipate based on the roll of land
where you want to pop up where you're
gonna have a good view what your winds
doing so that kind of stuffs good where
it gets goofy is they're building a
sequence where the two things aren't
tied you're just like taking b-roll or
like taking footage of this thing
[ __ ] around and then a hundred doing
like what looks plausible but when you
Wed the two together the behavior of the
deer and the behavior of the hunter
don't wet that was harmed in the making
of this film that's a dead deer can't
see a wound on it there might be a
little blood up there there's this kind
of like rawness to movies from this area
to see that it's like you're seeing the
life leave something we're kind of like
very in tune sort of sharp animals when
it comes to stuff like that this is like
you know this is like Adirondack do your
country this it's a little it's pretty
rugged for sure man the right kind of
territory that was the breakdown thanks
for watching